okay so Netflix have just dropped the
second volume of stranger things season
4. our ending explain for the full thing
is now here and throughout this video
we're going to be going through the plot
final few scenes and we'll also be
giving our thoughts on the finale it's
time to vacuum yourself before you rack
yourself one last time so turn it up to
11 and get into this Mammoth of a finale
that turns the entire show upside down
ball spoilers ahead from here on out and
with that out of the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
stranger things season four
[Music]
is going to be
beautiful
okay so we last left a lot of characters
at pivotal moments in the show Jose had
managed to make it out to hopper in
Russia 11's trip through Nina and
covered a big secret about Beckner and
elsewhere Nancy got stuck in his domain
as she learned the truth about him now
we start off exactly where the last
episode left off and huge shout outs to
Katie Lee for pointing out that during
the Face-Off between vector and 11 that
the rainbow actually flipped upside down
when it went to him this traumatic
moment in her life being recalled also
brought back her powers which are now
arguably more stronger than ever
matching how Wagner has grown as well
this Feud continues throughout the two
episodes with Beckner actually letting
Nancy go instead of the music box being
used like we theorized so L for us now
speaking of being freed we cut to Hopper
and Co who discover a lab attached to
the prison that contains elements of the
Mind player which are called The Shadow
rather than fleeing back to the us
though Hopper and the Gang decided to
stay behind in Russia to destroy the
upside down monsters that exist in the
prison come the end of the season Hopper
makes it back to Hawkins and this is the
true father and daughter relationship
that Brenner and owls was only a shadow
of love being empowering is very much a
theme throughout this season and
therefore I think that now hops home
it'll Empower 11 beyond where she's
already at she says goodbye to one
father figure early on in the volume and
therefore think hops more positive
influence on her will be crucial to
defeat Beckner next time now we
discovered that Wagner and the mind
flayer connected with one another in the
upside down when he was sent there by
11. Beckner ended up manipulating the
creature and he then turned the shadow
particles into the Mind flayer we
learned that he molded it and sent his
Beast into Hawkins creating somewhat
symbiosis with it this symbiosis is
something that we witnessed throughout
the seasons and the player of course
took over will in season 2. gun the end
of the entry will says that Wagner is
still alive and though he might not have
a physical form anymore he does still
exist out there it is possible that
Wagner could have even become Shadow
particles himself and this is how he
still survived long Beyond his body even
though he's beaten the teh he belt
ravages through Hawkins destroying
several parts of the town the official
stories that the devastation was caused
by an earthquake though there are people
that believe it was a satanic cult and
that the hellfire club were involved the
doorway into hell is thought of as just
being a conspiracy theory at the moment
but the truth of the matter will likely
come out soon areas of Hawkins start to
wither away and die ending up decayed
and darkness like the upside down sounds
so evil now the dimension is slowly
starting to bleed into Hawkins Beyond
what's come before and it might actually
take the death of a certain someone who
created the rift to close it once and
for all when 11 sent number one into the
upside down the entire thing began and
therefore I think Elle's death might
actually be a necessity in order to shut
things off for good now he also
discovered Dr Brennan's true intentions
in these episodes and it turns out that
he had a secret agenda like Netflix
always tells us trust no one and whether
it's squid game this or Umbrella Academy
I think it's hilarious how this Motif
keeps popping up I suppose suppose
Umbrella Academy it wasn't too bad
anyway after Dr Owens has a change of
heart Renner turns against the legend
jind and his true plan is revealed turns
out that through 11 he actually wanted
to try and find a way to connect with
Beckner once more this plan falls apart
when the military arrive and though he
survived the demogorgon attack in the
first season this time there's no
mistaking that he's killed once and for
all Brenner is shot by his sniper and 11
goes Force Unleashed on the chopper that
shoots him cementing how much he's
ground her match back now she needs his
strength too as his connection with the
shadow particles will make him more
powerful than ever and he might not even
go forth himself for season 5. just in
the same way that Brenner helped 11 to
grow her abilities the darkness in the
upside down has helped Beckner and
therefore I think a powerful emotion
like love will be needed to stop him now
Brenna also has a mask like death scene
hold me close red
it's getting dark
he was the cause 11 family and says that
he only wanted what was best for her
however that was a lie and he very much
had his ulterior motives that were
constantly driving him Alice shows her
true feelings towards him in the end and
though she could say something like I
love you Peppa she gives a pretty cold
goodbye see you chump also if you're
enjoying the video then please hit the
thumbs up whilst Brenner's thumb goes
down
like now again as I touched upon earlier
this death will likely leave her feeling
empty and therefore Hopper's return will
fill this void and Empower her to go to
the next level the battle at the prison
is brilliant and watching the group take
on the damned dogs and demogorgons is a
great action subplot and though a bit
distracting when you're watching the
main fight still works well now 11 is
rescued by Mike and the Gang and
learning that she created the big threat
in Hawkins makes her realize she needs
to save the world across the country the
other group of Pals Mount up and after
talking to Nancy they realize vechnel
likely becomes paralyzed when he's
astral projecting they head out to
defeat him and as always we get some
awesome 80s movies nods along the way
they Arm about war zone and the adverb
for this contains a character that looks
like Rambo there's also Michael Myers
mask and this belonged to Max because as
we know she dressed up as the character
for Halloween will also Reveals His
painting which is a Dungeons and
dragons-esque picture with the group
fighting a red Beast which is of course
playing on Wagner now Mike is labeled as
the heart and come on will yeah just
telemate and David Harbor also gets to
tout off his Christian Bale weight loss
program and he enjoys almost get it on
the group split up and Max leads him to
the creel house whilst the rest go with
my boy Steve you're my boy he and the
group then climb into the upside down
through Eddie's trailer the plan is to
lower Ragnarok through using Max's bait
and whilst he's paralyzed take him down
11 in the gang make an impromptu Nina in
the freezer and put in place what they
need to do to help eleven carry out her
psychic battle
now Max's plan works when she really
plays up her feelings of guilt and after
he appears as Lucas it once more puts
her into the trance that she experienced
in that Banger episode in the graveyard
absolute Banger although things start to
fall in place Steven the gang are
attacked by The Vines whilst the bats
swarm Eddie and Dustin this leads to
another big death in the season namely
an Eddie who gives the final performance
of his life great scene of him
sacrificing himself where he decides to
be a hero in order to save Dustin and
though I hated seeing him go was a nice
end to his Arc in which he learned to
stop running up that road and he run up
that hill now Eddie of course fell
cowardly after fleeing earlier in the
season and even though he's a newbie
this was the biggest death for me this
entry it hit hard when it initially
happened and then watching Dustin hand
over his plectrum that completely
wrecked me now 11 arrives in the upside
down to Battle it out with Beckner and
she saves Max at the last moment she
gets tied up and in the first moment of
compassion in his life 11 actually
reaches out to Henry and tries to talk
about Brenner she blames him for turning
him into the monster he's become but
Wagner very much sees it as her fault
and instead he discusses what happened
when he arrived in the upside down
Beckner of course wanted to wipe out
Humanity in order to save us from our
dull and meaningless lives and here he
finds a world that's Untouched by people
the Mind flayer then very much became
the way that he could transform into the
Predator that he'd always been born to
be this links back to his fascination
with spiders and it explains why the
Mind player it looks the way it does
Beckner ended up creating it and we get
to confirm that it's always been him his
psychic abilities and the combination of
the creatures allowed him to enact his
plan to find 11 in the hopes of
harnessing her powers initially he did
want her at his side but now he just
wants her to watch Mike professes his
love to her similar to Lucas and Max and
this further pushes her to break free of
vagner's grasp he also says she can fly
and move mountains and later they
reference Supergirl potentially heading
towards the more Powers being developed
in season 5. now vechner starts to
levitate Max in order to kill her but at
the last moment L breaks free and saves
Max before she becomes the Twister world
champion Murray burns the monsters out
in Russia and due to the hive mind that
the upside down has Nancy's Cooper freed
Hopper ends up going Aragon on the final
one and aragonna get you if you don't
please subscribe now Nancy in the gang
destroy vagner's body and get ready to
see running up that hill go to number
one again and again because this scene
bangs now after going Sarah Connor on
him Wagner is burned alive seemingly
time back to the Freddy Krueger
iconography Nightmare on Elm Street had
a character called Nancy this is how
Freddy was killed he of course tacked
people in dreams and Robert Englund made
a cameo in the season however we get
somewhat of a Halloween ending to it as
well with beckner's body not being there
when they go to check to make matters
worse being this close to death leaves
Max blinded and broken she's left in a
coma come the final closing scenes and
it's difficult to say whether she'll
stay this way or not her eyes make it
seem like she's blinded and creel senior
of course suffered from something
similar making me believe that she may
even end up staying this way technically
Max died but she's on the road to
recovery and I hope those broken legs
heal and she can keep running up that
road
sorry about that now keep going off into
it now the creel House Tears itself in
two and this wipes out not only Jason
but also most of the town this gave me a
lot of it Vibes and in the book upon the
defeat of Pennywise most of dirty was
destroyed this was downplayed for the
movie but there were incidents of
flooding and several citizens were
killed when Pennywise perished which I
believe they took inspiration from this
tear ends of opening the quote-unquote
doorway into hell and the Community
start to band together we get hints of
some romance between Vicky and Robin and
also a little tease towards Nancy and
Steve see you chump I will goes off into
a chilling speech about how Wagner is
still out there Desperately Seeking
everything and everyone he's likely
going to cause more psychic issues with
11 who's now trying to reach out to Max
through other means it's even possible
that he might exist in some form through
Max as he entered her brain and could be
being kept alive through that I think it
would be a big twist to learn that he'll
stay alive as long as she is and it
could take us into some really dark
territory you also get another Coca-Cola
reference with several of these showing
up throughout the season Harper then
returns home with Joyce and though it
should be a happy ending dark clouds
close in with the dust from the upside
down beginning to fall whale grabbing
his necklaces signifies that Wagner and
the mind player are close and this cloud
of Darkness blankets the entire area now
going forward I think we will watch as
the upside down merges with Hawkins and
as I talked about earlier this bleed
will cause the entire area to Decay and
die the clouds that shoot up into the
air end up looking like the Mind flayer
and this very much signals the villain's
arrival next time it's also important to
bear in mind that the mind player is how
Wagner very much views himself as being
and thus losing his body could make him
become this in his final form the upside
down also exists with a hive mind so it
makes sense that even in death one's
Consciousness could shift around now the
riffs and doorways can be closed by 11
however all that she's managed to do
before are smaller ones and I think this
could likely cost her her life the whole
series is built up around the idea of
sacrifice in order to save the ones that
someone loves and I think 11 dying in
order to finally close the gateways once
and for all will unfortunately end up
taking her too now there is the
possibility that she of course survives
which I would much prefer I could
actually see them doing something where
it seems like she's died but we learned
she's actually on the other side of the
upside down and locked herself in on the
way out this would be a clef hanger that
would give us some hope and there's lots
of possibilities going forward
now as for my thoughts on the whole
season I have to say I really loved it
for as strong as the other seasons are
this felt like a massive step up and
it's arguably up there as being one of
the best seasons of a show ever what's
more impressive is that we're four deep
whereas a lot of shows would be falling
off by now this continued to get better
every episode I think a lot of its
strength comes from the horror elements
and through having Wagner is a villain
in the past the series has suffered
slightly when it comes to them as
they've been monsters such as the
demogorgon and mind player though
they're intimidating they don't have
that human side of them that allows them
to actually have a character and making
vecon as someone who was originally
human was an inspired choice I think so
yeah nailed it on the villain for the
series now on top of this the group have
all really come into their own and
throughout the entry there's been some
brilliant arcs where they really had to
grow as people Hoppers surviving the
gulag was enthralling 11 having to take
a trip down memory lane to confront her
past was really gripping and there's so
many people that have been expanded upon
on in really interesting ways there's
also the general production of the show
this feels so cinematic throughout it
and you can definitely see the amount of
time and effort that they put into it
the budget is really on display here I
think it's one of those shows that
transcends TV haven't really got much to
criticize about it and normally when
episodes are super long like this I'd
bash the length or Pace of them but I
don't even really have an issue with
that when it's this gripping turning
into a shell gonna be a shillionaire by
the end of this and Netflix just back up
the money truck because Kevin's spoilers
is about to spoil himself with a spoiler
spending spree now but really great show
my only complaint is that it's over so
fast and hopefully in the future Netflix
set of weekly releases another
conversation is split on this but for as
good as this is I'd be happy to spend a
couple of months in Hawkins when it's
this high quality stranger things season
4 was excellent and it gets a 9.5 out of
10. and of course love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you comment below
and let me know but running a
competition right now giving away three
copies of everything everywhere all at
once in the 15th of July and all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we pick the comments out
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
boys which will be linked on screen
right now that last episode was
incredible and we've gone over the
entire thing so definitely check it out
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
Paul I'll see you in the next one take
care peace